very tough semi friends magnus was
wesley and
levon versus ding there's a bit of
chess competition today you could argue
but this is
as good as it gets here we are we have
liftoff
game number one e4 e5 knight f3
and knight c6 bishop c4 knight six
um i can't see the board yet can you
guys
and if you can why can't i those are the
questions i have
anyway i'll just assume
that you can see it i'm not sure why i
cannot
but here we are the italian is being
played
pawn to a5
the so-called joco piano choco
pianissimo
ah now i got it thank you here's the
show for me as well magnus carlsen
probably not thinking he can crush
one of the best prepared players in the
world in the opening wesley so
let's go for a very slow setup with his
bishop to c2
on to d5 queen to e2 computer not happy
with magnus's player saying knight 34
here
targeting this pawn and
black already putting a bit of pressure
now wesley goes a4 no magnus could take
the time to maybe stop that
with pawn to h3
if he chose to do so could also try to
open the position in the center that's
what he does
he takes d5 still keeping his options
open
at the center which takes
you cannot take this pawn yet typical
tactic
takes takes queen e5 bishop f2 knight g4
check
so magnus just to choose to develop a
piece bishop to e3
didn't get anything out of the opening
but we're just getting started
quite some background there for magnus
carlsen
from the hemingway suite i forgot
what the hotel was called the hotel that
is based
looks nice a little understated
beautiful
knight three bishop v6 the bishops got
traded
position is sort of stable now white
should throw an a3
yeah and he does so he never has to
worry about that pawn then bring
the rook to the middle and then dream
about playing pawn to d4
one day nothing special but
compared to the trouble he was in
earlier when wesley could have got mike
g4
this looks like a pretty good outcome
for the world champion here
with the white pieces against
at the very least online his greatest
rival recently
probably in his head or most of his
headspace will be consumed by jannie
publishing who's his rival
in the up and coming world championship
match in november and dubai
but online wesley so has been
a consistently strong
phone for the world champion he goes d4
knight takes e3
now pawn takes or queen takes
i seem to give white a nice position and
queen to d3
switching soup he's threatening queen h3
queen h7 check
and after g6 he does not recapture on d4
but goes after the b5 pawn arguing
you know what there's a pin on the d
file i'll pick up this pawn
and see if you manage to save any of
your material
bishop g4 trying to pin the knight but
white can unpin
by takes followed by rookie one which
should still give him
a bit of an edge as far as i could
custom thinking both players very evenly
matched on the clock
yeah here we are rook to e1 plate
queen c8 computer actually didn't like
rookie one says
it's equal now because now after knight
takes d4
knight takes d4 cd there is queen takes
c2 the queen
c8 does a great job covering everything
it's just here just so strong
wesley with these short tactics and you
can tell magnus missed this move queen
c8
doesn't look thrilled but wesley
i know if he looks thrilled but he does
have things under control here
quincy eight quite a move magnus here
now
has to eat a bit of humble pie here go
between e4 or something along these
lines
try to keep
and the position equal i guess
knight d2 plate trying to jump around
why socks is asking why isn't a4
dropping looks very dangerous to get the
bishop side
tracked here black would capture on f3
then capture on c3
then activate the roku k5 root g5
now you can't take on a4 like long term
it's a weakness but short term
no way you could let bishop f3 happen
there
dc plate and knight e4 magnus not even
covering the pawn what's going on if we
take here
he just wants to recapture and then say
long diagonal my friend
at least that's my guess
very dynamic solution by magnus carlsen
here
wesley goes bishop to f5 pawn takes c3
now you could get rid of this knight
before it gives any unpleasant checks
it doesn't allows the check
wesley is saying checkplace magnus
obliges just looks waiting for white now
tinies of headshakes from mr soap
okay five
trying to fight back with more tactics
magnus still
has to find the finish
queen b2 rook f5 c4
very quiet the computer says it
maintains a winning position
threat was rookie 8 check e5 but knight
d5
computer not a fan queen takes c4 knight
e3 and now there's queen e4
whoa pinning the rook and wesley is back
in business
so sharp these people
queen c3 rook g5 all of a sudden
wesley is a pawn up and anything could
happen king h1
drama
king j8 wesley really leaning into the
camera
and the position this would be
considered rude if you were playing over
the board his head would be like
on magnus's second rank but online
you can lean in as much as you want
i would assume wesley is not much
of a terror squad fan so he probably
doesn't want to lean back
what's going on now rook b5
rookie one and did he blunder this
because now
it seems like white is back in the
driver's seat
quincy one yeah quincy one plate and the
queen
leaves this king should
end up getting caught can't cover e8
and f6 at the same time as far as
i and more importantly the engine can
tell
this is it drama knight e7
that white takes the king has a luft on
h2
and magnus carson wins the first game
wesley's seen enough
leaves instantly